today is your lucky day the champ
uploaded a new video and you found it
I'm joking it's your lucky day because
Islam net is establishing a mega mid and
dawa Center and you have a unique
opportunity to be part of that so click
the link below and donate
now assalamu alaikum brothers and
sisters we're in the last 10 nights of
Ramadan and unfortunately the police in
Norway and the mosques are on high alert
why because we've received a terrorist
threat on a Discord server an
anti-muslim a right-wing extremist he
has posted a complete plan to come on
Monday and do a massacre in three named
mosques he's posted a picture of a
machine gun a military machine gun and a
hand pistol and he written the names of
those three mosques where he's going to
attack and has posted a picture from
Google maps showing the specific route
how to go from Masjid 1 to Masjid 2 to
Masjid
3 and do exactly what Brenton tarant did
in New Zealand brothers and sisters you
guys have been donating to establish the
mega Masid and da Center in Norway this
is your s this is your
Masid we cannot allow someone to
threaten the houses of Allah
that you guys have built and you guys
have invested in we need to protect the
house of Allah and alhamdulillah we've
already put up a proper security fence
around half the Masjid compound but we
need 500 of you to donate just
$100 to complete it we need to raise
$50,000 in these last blessed nights of
Ramadan and you can earn the tremendous
reward for protecting the house of Allah
for protecting the those people who come
and pray in the house of Allah and Allah
said in
thean believe in Allah and his
messenger and spend from that which he
has entrusted you
with so that those of you who believed
in Allah and you spent in the way of
Allah may have a tremendous a huge a
magnificent reward brothers and sisters
tonight may
be and you guys already know the
tremendous rewards
ofr if you do an act of worship on it is
as if you have done it in more than a
thousand months continuously Subhan so
just imagine giving a sodaka a charity
$100 for protecting the house of Allah
establishing the religion of Islam and
protecting the lives of the Muslims and
investing in your Masid the Masid that
you guys have built and you will get the
reward from that for a thousand months
of worship I don't know what's better
than that so click the link and donate
now